[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande halle
interviewe la france a franchi le cap
des quarante cinq mille morts depuis le
début de l'épidémie de coronavirus alors
que le pays est en pleine deuxième vague
d'une étude universitaire vient de
paraître qui s'intéressent à la
surmortalité lors de la première vague
avec un focus notamment sur l'île de
france région l'une des régions les plus
touchées par le kobe de 10,9 au
printemps l'un des auteurs de cette
étude est avec nous guy burgel
professeur de géographie urbaine à
l'université paris-x nanterre bonjour et
merci d'apriso et notre invitation votre
enquête réalisée notamment avec des
médecins portent donc sur la mortalité
de janvier à juin soit une période qui
va au delà du pic de l'épidémie en mars
avril elle porte aussi sur la région du
grand paris qu'est ce qui a motivé
justement ce focus précisément sur la
région parisienne
non mais je commencerai pas vous
répondre qu'est ce qui a motivé l'étude
avant même la région parisienne
c'est le fait que moi je suis très
frappé entre représentants des sciences
sociales par finalement le progrès
considérables qu'on a fait dans cette
pandémie sur l'aspect médical
épidémiologique vaccinale
c'est considérable et encore une fois ça
montre bien que la mondialisation n'a
pas que des mauvais côtés en un an on a
mis au poids pratiquement un bec
là il ya un déficit en sciences sociales
les deux côtés de la chaîne tiji ans
maman de la maladie commencé mon cette
vie de once au congo et en aval les
conséquences finalement qui sont
catastrophiques sur la population en
tout cas qui sont angoissantes sur la
population de cm2 bonté de dieu
on a tout oublié les charges sociales
sont dire encore une fois qu'il fallait
négliger tout ce qui est médicale virale
épidémiologique et c'est la deuxième
chose bauchi parisien parisien et
d'implantation professionnel et
universitaire est au fond le grand paris
c'est dit les trois départements faut
quand même dire ce que c'est c'est des
trois départements de la petite couronne
c'est à dire les hauts-de-seine
seine-saint-denis et val-de-marne la
ville de paris bon ben ça trésor mme 7
millions d'habitants et c'est un terrain
d'aventuré si j'ose dire en termes d
observation encore une fois qui n'a eu
pour vertu que sa diversité sa
complexité et sa richesse
donc vous savez cartographier les zones
d'île de france où la mortalité a le
plus progressé
de la première vague est votre constat
est le suivant ce sont la moitié nord et
le sud est de la métropole qui sont
davantage concert je n'ai pas répondu
pourquoi chez moi parce que deux
formations si j'ose dire il faut
observer pour moi sur une assez longue
durée si on verra lequel s géographique
on a quand même des cartes à l'échelle
de la commune à l'échelle des vingt
arrondissements parisiens
il faut avoir une grande amplitude de
temps parce que les sénats même
démographique à ça sans entrer dans les
détails ont toujours une certaine dit
merci
donc c'est vrai qu'on n'a d'ailleurs
d'observation cinq mois et demi pour
être très exact d'un 1er janvier 2020 15
juin devienne pas un peu plus large même
beaucoup plus large que le petit vous
attendez me qu'on voit bien d'ailleurs
ce mot couvent en avril et en mai bon
alors les conclusions justement n'en
sont que plus remarquable si j'ose dire
parce que justement comme on a une
période d'observation longue on peut
être à peu près assuré que ce que nous
découvrons trouvons après d'autres avec
peut-être plus de précision géographique
est valable alors en effet quelle est la
principale conclusion la principale
conclusion c'est qu'on a une
surmortalité quand on compare ce qui
s'est passé pour le premier semestre
2010 à la moyenne des deux semestres
précédents les âmes et 2018 et 2009
on a exactement une meilleure
représentation inverse de la mortalité
c'est à dire que pour aller vite
la mortalité dans cette zone du grand
paris ces quatre départements donc j'ai
retracé
elle est essentiellement dans les
quartiers aisés ou la population plus
âgée on a normalement une mentalité qui
est lié à la structure darche
eh bien on a exactement l'inversé le
sont dans les rides dyson populaire à
problèmes pour aller vite qu'ils sont
jeunes où on a une surmortalité c'est à
dire essentiellement le 93 à cette année
et le nord des hauts-de-seine vers la
boucle ce qu'on appelle la boucle de la
seine qui va consciemment de
gennevilliers à à nanterre donc ça nous
a interpellés et en pousse un petit peu
plus loin je vous donne tout de suite la
conclusion pourrait rebondir si vous
voulez bon la conclusion c'est que
finalement qu drama à la tente
ce ne sont pas encore une fois des
personnes jeu
qui aurait travaillé dans les conditions
de transport de métier de profession
difficile
ce sont des personnes âgées recommandés
sont des personnes âgées des quartiers
jeune c'est ou ça c'est pas nos fins
mais des personnes âgées des quartiers
jeunes populaires à problèmes
économiques sociaux et cetera qui sont
les plus affectées et on est amené à
penser mais c'est selon les hypothèses
parce que tant qu'on n'aura pas fait
dans lequel direct pour le prouver
ce sont bien des hypothèses plausibles
et finalement il y a des contagions
intergénérationnel va dire de plusieurs
générations qui vivent dans des
appartements plus ou moins exiguë et
bout et ce sont des actes et qui
certainement contamine les personnes
âgées les primaires où les crampes herbe
et qui sont affectés à la fois par la
morbidité goggin et les malheureusement
par la mentalité clair selon votre étude
c'est toute la moitié nord et le sud est
de la métropole qui sont davantage
concernés par la surmortalité compte à
l'envers sans les banlieues des
arrondissements parisiens de l'ouest et
du centre le son d'un mois et dans ces
zones les plus touchées par la
surmortalité vous notez donc que si la
population y plus jeunes ce sont
majoritairement les personnes les plus
âgées qui sont décédés c'est bien ça
mais alors du coup quelques jours est ce
qu'on peut en tirer on peut en tirer que
sont les jeunes qui propagent le virus
ou bien entre en compte aussi dans ses
hommes et plus touchés par la
surmortalité là le difficile accès aux
soins est ce qu est ce qu'aujourd'hui on
est capable de conclure non on n'est pas
capable de conclure mais malheureusement
en sciences sociales les progressions
paris peut-elle successives vérifier
veut dire que finalement on est amené à
émettre l'hypothèse de causalité de
causalité c'est à dire qu encore une
fois il ya certainement des contagions
mais je reviens ici je jubile envoyer
c'est l'incertitude mais j'assume
l'interdît
il ya des chaînes de contagion du second
à l'intérieur rassemblement du milieu
familial pense que on a des familles qui
vivent à trois générations les enfants
les parents qui travaillent au moins
dont l'un des membres travaillent et
peut-être non un grand père une
grand-mère qui vit avec eux dans mes
appartements qu'ils sont
certainement assez exigu il ya une
contagion qui se propage certainement
toujours ce terme certainement par les
adultes qui a fait les personnes âgées
et des personnes âgées qui sont un sens
le sait par ailleurs en situation
finalement de comorbidité c'est à dire
qu'ils sont quelquefois en surpoids en
diabète maladies chroniques etc et où
l'accès aux soins dans ces quartiers
difficiles peuvent à la fois manque de
structures par aussi insuffisance de
connaissance des populations
finalement au moins de facilité d'accès
aux soins et de moindres rapidité il ya
des cons causalité qui ne sont pas liées
entre elles mais dont les seins lui et
certains alors pour s' pour lever cette
incertitude ou pas ces deux hypothèses
plus ou moins valides à la certitude il
faudrait les banques et des saveurs peut
repartir de l'autre bout tu nous
militons toute l'équipe pour qu'on
puisse repartir de l'autre bout de la
chaîne connaît nous sommes partis de
statistiques démographiques et nice par
l'insee sont lourdes à traiter mais
quand même une histoire lindsay pourrait
repartir de dossiers de spécialisation
pour être assurés que finalement la
chaîne causale m'étonne pas son album
est donc parmi ces hypothèses que vous
faites dans la foulée de cette étude
cette double caractéristique qui
concerne donc les zones les plus
touchées par la surmortalité des actes
des habitants qui ont donc les revenus
nets des niveaux de revenus les plus bas
qui vivent dans les logements les plus
exigus de la métropole mais finalement
c'est peut-être pas forcément le niveau
de revenu qui explique cette
surmortalité mais elle peut être
expliquer aussi par un mode de vie
particulier notamment peut-être une
cohabitation intergénérationnelle donc
finalement c'est pas forcément une
histoire d'argent le kobe 19 en
l'occurrence ne touche pas forcément les
plus pauvres mais ce qui
en mode de vie plus particulier là vous
interpella vous interpeller directement
le géographe urban je suis c'est à dire
que finalement dans la ville l'espace
n'est qu'un support
nous avons de ce qu'on appelle bon dans
le salon mais j'ai essayé d'expliquer
déco spatialité c'est à dire les
superpositions dans le même espace les
deux causes qui sont indépendantes
encore une fois vous voulez avoir des
comorbidités des appartements exigus des
revenus qui seront eux-mêmes assez exigu
des cdd chômage et de sous-emploi
malheureusement aussi chronique que les
maladies et c'est tout cet ensemble de
causes qui constitue finalement un
complexe syndrome en quelque sorte
social et dont le président est à la
fois le révélateur est malheureusement
la cause déterminante ponctuel mais
encore une fois on a certainement la
révélation de situation structurelle
alors votre étude démontre aussi un a
priori l'épidémie ne paraît pas avoir
entraîné une mortalité particulière chez
ceux qu'on a appelés les premiers de
corvée c'est ce sont ceux qui
travaillent dans la logistique les
personnels soignants qui ont pourtant
maintenu leur activité dans des
conditions de transports collectifs
notamment ils n'ont pas été
particulièrement touché par cette
surmortalité est coupée voilà vous a
tout à fait compris une découverte sedan
ça c'est un bien grand mot bord
une des choses qui m'a le plus
personnellement et peu mais moi je
m'attendais à ce qu'il y ait en effet
ces premiers de cordée ce qu'ils sont
sur la ligne 13 par exemple toujours
décrié bon qui travaillent dans des
conditions difficiles qui ont transporté
dans des conditions difficiles
eh bien on ne pense pas qu'ils à une
surmortalité de cette frange balle alors
on a fait d'étranges bad dans notre
masse d'eau mais de 25 à 65 ans dans des
actifs en tout cas des supposés ou des
réputés mais il n'y a pas de
surmortalité
c'est à dire que finalement il n'y a pas
plus de surmortalité voyez ce sens entre
la complexité on a finalement toujours
structurellement il mortalité un peu
plus importante dans ces quartiers
difficiles parce qu'il ya des mobilités
acquise parce que lescar pau aller vite
l'espérance de vie elle est un peu moins
bonne mais là c'est assez sensiblement
moins bonne dans ces quartiers
populaires que dans les quartiers
bourgeois dans les banlieues bourgeois
de l'ouest parisien
mais si m
le coach n'a rien révélé de spécifique
par rapport aux périodes précédentes
autrement dit ce ne sont pas près
semblable en été c'est là qu'on arrive à
la chaîne causale
non seulement il n'y a pas de
surmortalité de ses premiers de converse
apparente dernier toujours dans la
parente parce qu'on les laisse à des
sites qui l on prête ne traite des
conséquences encore une qu'on ne prenne
pas des causalités on ne peut pas tant
qu'on n'a pas fait des enquêtes viennent
on n'a pas de cette pause al en ab on a
simplement des conséquences comme quand
on consomme comme si c'est elle la trace
en quelque sorte du passage d'un avion
d'un satellite dans le ciel voilà c'est
satellite rascom marque dont il n'y a
pas encore une fois de surmortalité
cesser ces personnes qui travaillent
dans des conditions qui sont transportés
dans des conditions difficiles et pré
semblablement mais ça commence à sortir
dans d'autres phénomènes on pense
qu'elles sont les docteurs c'était
personnes pour les les membres de leur
famille ils vivent dedans sous un même
toit
alors à tous derniers mots justement
quelle est la conséquence que vous tirez
en ce qui concerne la ville
est ce que la ville dense et mortifère
en soi et ce cas les facteurs de
contagiosité ce sera ma dernière
question donc urgent tout faire pour
doucher vous touchez là abeilles pape
problème parce que je ne savais pas la
densité
j'affiche peu beaucoup paris intra muros
les 20 arrondissements dans le boulevard
périphérique connaissent bien nos
téléspectateurs en tout cas tu arrives
bien et même les provinciaux et bien et
deux fois trois fois plus dense que
toute la banlieue que la banlieue de
cette famille que la bourre des hawks 1
3 fois plus dense donc la densité brut
dire que les mégapoles et d'autres potes
sont plus affectées pas du tout et on a
les mêmes on a les mêmes pour cela sur
mes collègues new yorkais sont des pubs
sur la les statistiques videmment aussi
de mortalité morbidité qu'ovide dans la
métropole new-yorkaise serait pas
manhattan qui est affecté c'est le
queens et le bronx autre bande est ce
son et ce sont les populations latinos
ou afro américaine qui sont les plus
affectés aux commandes et ce n'est pas
la densité brut c'est-à-dire le rapport
entre la population du territoire
secteur qui est porteur de causalité
d'explications mais des densités un
train si je le dis au département est un
départ ce matin
l'appartement excusez-moi bon tenir les
deux bouts de la chaîne
on compte en un peu le coup à des
réalités ou à des vérités qui semble
acquis l'adversité entraîne la contagion
bah c'est pas la densité c'est pas la
densité brut
encore une fois les personnels et les
personnes actives pour être plus
affectée pas du tout c'est toujours les
personnes âgées mais c'est pas les mêmes
personnes âgées
une chose est de ça et une personne âgée
dans un appartement exigu de 200
familles sur des une personne âgée
dentelliers maroni
wang yi merci beaucoup guy burgel
toujours très classe et votre étude
sujet donc de cette surmortalité duo
kobe 19 lors de la première vague avec
ce focus sur l'île de france rappelle
donc que vous êtes professeur de
géographie urbaine à l'université
paris-x nanterre
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis je
vous pouvez retrouver cette grande
interview sur notre site rt france ptv à
plus tard
[Musique]